では始まります 今までこのラーフラワーダという経典の説明をいたしまして
この経典ではお釈迦様がお釈迦様が考えている道徳観を説明していたんですね
ですから このあまり気持ち悪くする必要はない
それはお釈迦様が考えている道徳観であって
世の中ではいろいろ道徳観がございますので
それに攻撃したんだとかね
私の個人的な道徳観にいろいろ悪口言われたとか
そういうふうに思う必要は全くないんです
認めるならば認める 捨てるならば捨てると
まあそれどちらでもよろしいし
こっちの経典ではお釈迦様が考えている道徳って何なのかと
お釈迦様の子供でしたけど
これは son じゃ その時はすごい小さな子供でしたからね
まあ教えた経典なんですね
で それ全部終わりましたので
今日はもう本当はやるところはございませんが
ヤデワタンラーフラマナサーカンマンカットゥカーモホーシタデーワテーマノカンマンパッチヤイッティタッバン
で 今度はこのマナサーカンマンカットゥカーモホーティ
もしラーフラあなたは心で行為をしたいと思うならば
で 心の行為っていうものは仏教で考えてるんですね
で そこも世俗世間の思考とは違うかもしれませんけど
まあ間違ってるんではないかと
行為っていえば もう体でやることではないかというふうに思っている場合もあるし
しかし仏教では言葉で喋ることも行為ですよと言ってるし
カンマと言うんですね
で 体でやることも行為だと言ってるんですね
それから心で考えることも行為だと仏教では言ってるんですね
だからそこら辺ははっきりした方がいいんですね
私たちは何考えたっても
それはそれですごく自由なんです
仏教ではこういう風にあるんだよとちょっとだけでも覚えておけば
すごくありがたいことなんですね
それでこの心でする行為って何なのかと
いわゆる仏教においては
体でする行為 言葉でする行為
心でする行為という こういう 3つが考えているんです
で それがその中で 今日は心の行為に対して道徳的な判断的に判断する方程式をお釈迦様が教えているんですね
それで心でする行為といえば何でしょうかと
それは考えることなんですね
で 世の中では考えることはどうったことはないと罪にならないとは思ってます
全ての世界では どなたでも
で そこはもう諸宗派の仏教は考えることもやっぱり善悪判断するべき道徳的な判断するべき行為だとハッキリした行為として見ているんですね
そこはすごい違うところだよと理解してほしいんです
で 世の中で考えていることはちょっと違うんだからといって
仏教に対して攻撃するってことは
それはそれでいいんですけど
自分たちが侮辱されたと思うのは
それは勘違いだって間違いなんだよ
侮辱してるわけじゃないんです
仏教では違うことを言ってるだけのことです
ですから お釈迦様の教えでは
心で考えることさえも行為そのものなんです
それで大乗仏教では重善戒という素晴らしい戒律というものを持っているというふうに思っているんですね
小乗仏教にはもう何もないって
五戒だけではないかとかね
で この重善戒っていうのは
初期仏教では戒律ではありません
ただ 善と悪の項目なんですね
善と悪の項目が戒律にはなりません
ですから それはもう戒律といえばどんな定義かということの問題であって
初期仏教になると もう戒律っていうのはある社会的な決まり
それから個人で自分の人生はどんな決まりの中で管理するかっていうことであって
それは増えたり減ったりすることもできるし
人が人格的にきちんと生活しているならば
こんな項目なんかは必要ではありませんし
人間は足で歩くべきですよということは戒律にはなりませんし
なぜならば誰でも足で歩いているんだから
しかし 歩きながら周りにもいろいろ石を投げたりするんだったら
歩くときは周りに石を殴るべきではありませんというふうに言わなくてはいかん
それは戒律になるんですよ
ですから この戒律の定義っていうのは
普通の生き方 社会に関わる生き方と個人自分の生き方を整理するためのものであって
善と悪という道徳判断というのは
これはもっとすごい普遍的なものであって
人間の個人的な気持ちとは何の関係もないものなんです
普遍的な真理であると
個人が何考えてるかっていうことは
個人の好み 個人の自由っていうのは
道徳の場合は効かないんです
効かないというか 通じない
通用しないんですね それで仏教ではこの重善と重悪というものは普遍的な真理として
道徳的な真理として成り立ってますね
それはどこ どんな経典見ても
どんな経典でもなくて
その項目 善悪に立ち触る経典だったら
必ずその重善重悪が出てくるんです
ですから その中でみんな知ってる
殺生するな 盗むなかれと
欲情ない行為するなかれという体の行為三つ
それから嘘を言うな 悪口を言うな
噂を言うな 悪口を言うなという言葉の行為三つ
それから怒りと欲ですね
その場合も不自然的な怒りと欲
いわゆる人間 生命が自分の命を守るためにどうしても必要な怒り
論理的な怒りと欲というものではありません
この論理を崩れてしまって
ちょっと精神的に異常
異常になっている怒りと欲というところをはっきりしているんですよ
例えば動物同士でも 他の動物が攻撃してきたら
こちらの動物も攻撃しなくちゃいけないんですよ
その場合はそちらは怒りで喧嘩するんですね
動物の世界で交尾する時は
オスたちがどうしても喧嘩しなくちゃいけないことになっているんです
そこで喧嘩したところで
勝った動物は交尾すると
だから そういう自然の設立する中で
どうしても生命の維持するために必要な怒りと欲というものはあるんですね
動物も欲がなければ交尾もできませんし
ですから このそこら辺ではある論理的理性を持っているんですね
動物は だから動物 オス同士で喧嘩するのは繁殖時期だけなんですね
それからは全然喧嘩することも何もなく
互いに平和で生活する
で 欲出すのも これはもうメスたちがその妊娠する時期になったならば
欲を出して交尾をしようとするのであって
そうではないと何のことなく
すごく穏やかで平和で
動物たちは生活しているんですよ
ですから ものすごい理性というか
理性 論理を守っているんですね
だからそちらに何か道徳的に云々と言ったっても
これは自然な設立だから
まあそれはちょっとどうにもならないことで
それで それを超えて この論理的なレベルを破っていっちゃうと精神的な病気なんですね
だからそういう怒りと欲っていうのは
まあわかりやすく言えば
身を守るためにどうしても必要な怒り
欲っていうのはもうしょうがないんですね
どんな生命でも自分で生きていきたいというふうに
死にたくはないというふうに思っているんだから
その身を守る範囲を超えちゃうと
その怒りと欲っていうのは異常であって
破壊的であって 自己破壊
他人の破壊になっている精神的な異常なんですね
その精神的な異常な欲と怒りは
仏教では心の行為として罪
てるんですね それから邪見というのはもう考え方自体が間違って変ということなんですね
考え方変だったらどうにもなりません
物事をありのままに見るべきなんですね
自分で湾曲して自分で好みで見るべきではないんですよ
丸いものは丸いと 四角いものは四角いと
長いものは長いと理解するべきなんですよ
それで かえってまた変で
何か角度を 何か尺度を持って
何か色眼鏡を持って世の中を見ること自体が邪見というんですね
そうすると 正しく物事は一つも見えませんね
それが邪見というんです
それで そちら 3つなんですね
体でする行為は 3つと
言葉でする行為は 4つと
それで 7つ それから頭でする行為は 3つと
そこで当が成り立つのですね
当の悪 反対は当の善なんですね
それが生命である限り
誰にでも同じことなんです
動物でもこの命を守るために必要な怒りと欲を超えちゃうと
もう罪を犯しているんですよ
人間でも同じことなんですね
だからこの とにかく動物の世界ではあまり道徳っていうのは語りませんが
善悪はあるんですよ 動物も殺生すると
それは罪なんです 動物も盗みをすると
それは罪なんです それは動物は知っているかないかと関係ないんですよ
動物は知らないんだと
だったら同じ論で人間にも当てはまる
当てはまるはずなんですよ
盗むことは悪いと知らないんだと
だから盗んでるんだからしょうがないと言ってもね
それでしょうがないわけじゃないんですよ
だから個人が知ってるか知ってないかということは関係なく
罪は罪 悪は悪という 善は善というふうに言っているのは
それは仏教の世界 他の人
文化ではどういうふうに考えているかということは
それは仏教には関係ないんです
もしそういう違う思考あるならば
後で話し合って いろいろ照らし合わせてみればよろしいことで
私の仕事は仏教はどういうふうに言っているかということで
できるだけ比較することはやめます
それで善と悪ということは
誰がしても同じことだと
善はいいことで 悪は悪いことで
善行為したら良い結果が出てきて
悪行為すれば悪い結果が出てくる
それはもう避けられませんと
誰にでも それは因果法則ですから
個人の関係ではありません
個人個人の存在もないと
個人と言ったっても それも因果法則によって組み立てられている組織しか何もないんですよ
誰でも因果法則によってそれぞれ組み立てられている組織のみですね
その組織がずっと変化して変わっていくプロセスだけなんです
そのプロセスだからね
それで個人個人がいるわけじゃないんですね
ですから どんなプロセスであろうとも
ある法則によって変化しなくちゃいけない
その法則のことを言っているだけで
法則もいろいろたくさんありますから
そこで一つ因果法則 悪い方向に行く
良い方向に行くという場合は
こういう善悪というふうに判断になっているんですね
そういうわけで 重善重悪っていうのは犬も猫も守らなくちゃいけないことなんですよ
それで犬は知らないと言ったってもね
言ったっても知らないんですよ
こちらでは 別に 悪いことしたらもう罪を起こしちゃうんですよ
良いことをしたら もうそれはもう善行為をしたことになるんです
それはもうどうにもならんことなんですよ
だからまあ仏教の人々は
この動物の世界なんかに生まれ変わることは絶対嫌がるんですね
もうとにかくそれは極力嫌がって
毎日もう何かいいことをしたらもう誓願するんですよ
で 一発で悟るわけでもないし
悟るまで輪廻転生しなくちゃいけないし
ですから もう決してそういう４つのね
地獄 餓鬼道 もうなんとかなんとか阿修羅とかね
そういうところにだけには
だけは絶対生まれないようにと
どうせ生まれるのならば
人間か天界かどこかで生まれるようにと
人間の世界で生まれるんだったら
まあ欲だけいい加減な
このもう贅沢だけの贅沢三昧だけで
また地獄に落ちるような環境では生まれないようにと
人間に生まれても 善悪に対してすごい興味のあるどこかの社会環境で生まれるようにと
かなり明確に良いことを何かお布施したら
法事をしたら 必ず最後にそういうふうに誓願するんですよ
で どういうことかと それは文化的な考え方で
で 皆様にとっては何かえらいなじみのない思考かもしれませんですけど
それは仏教徒の文化的な思考で
そちらで見えるのはすごいこの動物の世界に生まれることはものすごく嫌がるということなんです
で そういうわけなんですね
なんでこの文化的に牛とかね
インド文化では一応牛なんかはヒンドゥー教では聖なる動物になっていて
また馬やらゾウやらね
いくつかの動物たちはすごくありがたがっている
なぜかというと この仏教でも牛なんかはありがたがってます
聖なる動物とは言わないんですけど
大変ありがたい動物やと
なぜか自分では罪を犯さないんですよ
喧嘩しないんですよ で
オス同士でちょっと喧嘩するんですけど
それはもう決まってることで
そんなに恐ろしい喧嘩にはなりません
まず牛だったら このオス同士顔を合わせたら
まずこの威嚇するだけ
俺が強いぞと すごくまず威嚇する
犬と同じく土をもう後ろ足で前足でも蹴ったり掘ったりする
それからそこら辺 木とかね
このなんかちょっとしたこの土の壁みたいなものあったら
そこにものすごい声出しても
角で蹴って攻撃して見せたりする
それで威嚇するんですね
ほら 私の体力を見なさいと
それで相手がやっぱりやべえと思ったらもう控えていく
それぐらいは何のこともないと
自分でも同じことすると
それで勝ち負け決めませんだから
それでもう顔を合わせちゃうんですよ
で 怪我する場合はあるんですけど
結局どちらが力強いかっていうことを確かめるだけで
力弱いなと 頭で引っ張ると
後ろの後ろにもう2 3歩下がってくると
もうその牛はもう下がって帰っていっちゃうんですね
やっぱりダメやと 相撲と同じで
もう別に力 ほんのちょっとのことで負けたらもう負けっていうことになってるような感じなんですね
で もう倒れても蹴ったりすることはしません
それで生活するためには罪を犯せませんね
牛は それだけじゃなくて
牛がいることで人間なんかはものすごい役に立っている
もう田んぼの仕事やら荷物を運ぶことやら
牛乳飲むことやら 牛乳からあらゆる食べ物を製品作ったりするでしょ
それでものすごいもうもう昔そんな肉魚食べることなかったでしょうと思いますけど
すごい人間に対してはもうかけがえのない動物ですから
なんてありがたいですかと
ですから 世の中では財産って何なのかというところで
お釈迦様がナッティゴーサミタンダナン
牛ほどの財産はありませんと
当時の文化に合わせて言ってるんですね
一番高価な財産って何なのかと聞かれたら
それは牛ですよと ですから
そういう文化的にこの牛
ゾウとかね まあまあ立派な動物だよととは言っていることは
やっぱりその動物の生き方を見ると
罪を犯さないで生活している
そういうことで 私が何を言いたがっていますかというと
この十善十悪っていうのは全ての生命に
機能する法則なんです
私が知らないと言ったっても
それは言い訳になりません
私の宗教違いますよと言っても
それも言い訳になりません
私は無神論者だよと言ったっても
だから何ですかと 悪いことしたら悪いんだよと
という態度なんですね
だから宇宙の法則と同じことなんですよ
例えばオゾン層が穴が開けて紫外線が入ってくると
それで私は別に全然オゾン層を破壊するために何も悪いことをしてないんだよと
私はそういう あの 何て言いますか
なんとかとガスなんか使ったこともないんだよとか言っても
だからその人に紫外線が
じゃあやっぱりこの人に攻撃してはいけませんよと言って逃げていくわけじゃないんですよ
それも法則だから 地球に住んでいる誰にでももうそれが当たることは当たるんですよ
だから言い訳は効かないということなんです
法則っていうのはそういうもので
我々の個人的な言い訳は効かない
毒を飲んだ人は 私は死にたくないんですから死にませんよと言っても
そんなわがままは効かないんですよ
毒を飲んだならば その人は死ぬ
それが法則ですよ 個人好みのわけがない
そういうわけで 知っているか知らないかということは関係ない
罪は罪で 悪は悪で そういうことだから
重善重悪は戒律として設定はしません
戒律でなくても守らなくてはいけないことなんです
戒律を設定すると これは仏教徒だけの仕事になるんですよ
戒律になると 別に他の人が守る必要ないんだから
キリスト教にはキリスト教の戒律があります
イスラム教にはイスラム教の戒律があります
ヒンドゥー教にはヒンドゥー教の戒律があります
仏教徒は別に何でイスラム教の戒律を守らなくちゃいけないんですか？守る必要ないんです
それぞれの考え方の中で自分たちに合う戒律を作ったりする
なんか意味がわからないんだけど
カトリック教会なんかに行く場合は
女の人は何か頭に何か被っちゃうでしょ？お祈りする時とかね
それはそちらの決まりであって
こちらで私が行って何か文句言ったっても何の意味もないんですね
何かお祈りすると雨でも降ってくるんでしょうかと
あるいは神の恵みが来るのは嫌でやってるんでしょうかとか
そんなことを言うのは仏教徒のいい加減であって
その人々は何らかの訳があってやっているでしょうにね
そういうことだから 重善重悪はこの初期仏教では戒律としては設定しない
それは生命 生命たるものはみんなもう気をつけた方がいいと
生命たるものはもう生命は誰でも
人間だけに限ったものでもないと
それは不幸になる 幸福になる法則ですよと
そこでその戒律としてなってくると
そのその人の生活 例えば在家の人々の場合は
まあやっぱり五戒ぐらい守りなさいと
特別に もう五戒の中でも当然殺生するなかれもあるし
盗むなかれもあるし で
邪淫な行為するなかれもあるし
そこで欲を幾ら管理してもらうし
嘘をつくなかれと言っているし
それで終わっちゃうんですね
でも噂話や無駄話は絶対して
戒律で決めちゃうと絶対守らなくちゃいけないんですよ
でも人間が社会ではもうよくやっていることだから
もうこれちょっと言うとちょっときつすぎなんですね
だから罪として 噂話 無駄話
悪口はよくないよ だったらあんたひどい目に遭いますよと
でも厳密に守る決まりとしては
嘘を言うことはやめてくださいと
それぐらいは頑張れるでしょうということなんですね
で そこはもう大乗仏教になってくると
戒律を捨てて重善重悪を戒律にしているんですね
しかし守ってないと で
面白いことなんですね
重善重悪を守ったってもう立派なもんですよ
これすごい立派なものですよ
そう簡単には守らないんだから
あらゆる戒律を設定して
あらゆるふうに自分の生き方に制限してもらって
苦労して守るんですよ
で 完全に守りたければ
もう煩悩をなくさなくちゃいけない
無知をなくさなくちゃいけない
無知だから罪を犯しているんですね
だからそう簡単ではないんですね
無知がある限りは もうキリがないんですね
これはもう体をきれいにすることと同じことなんですよ
体っていうのは汚れたものだから
これ毎日毎日きれいにしておかないと
もう悪臭でも もうものすごい悪臭なんですよ
いっぱい細菌が隅々についてるでしょうし
ですから そこで体のもう細胞壊れて死にかけてる死んだ細胞とくっついちゃうと
ものすごい恐ろしい悪臭が出てくる
だから毎日毎日洗って洗って洗って洗って
もう服まで汚れますよ
着たら それぐらい体っていうのは汚いものなんですね
そこでキリがありますかと
キリがないんですよ 死ぬまでやらなくちゃいけないんです
その仕事は で それそれがたとえで
我々の心が煩悩というか無知で汚れているんだから
毎日踏ん張らないと罪を犯さずいられないんですよ
毎日朝から晩まで 24時間体制で気をつけないと
もうすぐ罪を犯しちまう
悪いことをしてしまっちゃう
ですから この十善十悪を守るっていうことを
十善を守って十悪をやめるということは
そんな半端な気持ちでできるものじゃないんです
あまりに難しいんだから
いろいろ方法が まあ戒律として出ているんですよ
だから戒律の狙いというか
もう目的はこの十善十悪を守ってもらうこと
それが仏教の基本的な善と悪という項目ですね
善は何ですか？悪は何ですか？で言えば
この 10項目になるんです
その中で この順番 リストはどのようにできたかというと
体 言葉 心という身 口 意という順番なんですね
そこで なんでその順番にしたかというと
この罪の重さがこの軽いところから重いところまで
いわゆるこの上り順番なんです
上り順番で言ってるんです
上り順番で言ってるんだから
1番目は殺生  2番目は盗む
3番目はよこしまな行為とになってます
それで殺生することを盗むこと
よこしまな行為をすることよりも罪が重いんですよ
嘘を言うと それよりも
まあ悪口 悪い人ですれな言葉を言うと
すごく怒りで言ってるんだから
もっと罪が重いんです
噂流しちゃうと もっとひどいんですよ
タチが悪いんですね 人が仲良くしているのに
それは壊しちゃう 壊してやるぞと
潰してやるぞと 恐ろしいんですね
悪口場合はもう腹が立って
もう我慢できなくて もう罵ってるだけだから
別にそんなにタチが悪いっていうことじゃないんですよ
ですから 順番で見てみると罪が重いっていうことはわかるんですよ
まあ嘘ぐらいはもう冗談でも言ってしまっちゃうし
そんなに 巧なくてもそういう場合もありますしね
で 悪口はそうじゃないんですね
もう腹が立っても我慢できなくて言ってることで
噂話はもっと質が悪いんですね
綺麗な言葉使って あることもないことも何でも流してしまって
しまして 人の秩序 平和を
調和を壊すんですね だからずいぶん悪いと
無駄話いうことはもっと悪いんだと
なぜならば無駄話だから
人の時間は全くもなくなるし
それで言葉が上手で巧みだったら
かなりの人々にダメージを与えることはできるんですね
それでダメージ受けるんだけど
受ける側も全然気が付かないんですね
麻薬中毒みたいなもんなんですね
ものすごいダメージ これは経済的にもかなりダメージを受けるんですよ
無駄話のせいで このいろいろ会議やらいろんな話し合いになってくると
何日何日もかかる 国会にしたっても四十五日間でしたっけ
もう延長までしなくて
一日どれぐらいお金がかかるかというと
なぜかというと 思い存分無駄話言うんだからなんです
ちょっとした法律ももう決められません
話し合って話し合って話し合って
棚上げにする 最終的には
だから いかに無駄かというとね
だからこの世の中では
この無駄話のせいでもう払える財産が消えてしまっているんですよ
それで不幸になるんですよ
でも世の中では全然気にしない
無駄話なんかそれはいいんじゃないかと
だからそれは世の中の考え方で
私が説明してるのはお釈迦様の考え方で
どちらが認めるか正しいと思うのは
それはもうそれぞれ皆様方は自由であって
世の中ではもう政治やらそう無駄話することっていうのはもう大変な素晴らしい人間ができているんだからやっていることだと思っているかもしれません
しかし ブッダはお釈迦様が全く違う立場を取っていて
これがもう巨大なもう財産の損で
もうとんでもないことだと
人間の成長はそのまま妨げてしまっちゃいますよと
無駄話っていうのは いくら聞いてもいくら聞いても知恵が育てないんですよ
知識になりません 一時間聞いても
五時間聞いていても 一日聞いていても
何か知識を得たということは何一つもないんです
まあ例えば歴史の話でも聞いていると
もう歴史的に起きた事実だから
歴史的なもう過去の事実を知ったぞっていうことになるでしょうね
昔何が起きたんですかと
どのようにそれ起きたんですかと
それで知ったんだよということで
知識に何か付け加えるんですよ
無駄話の場合は知識に何も付け加えません
そういうことで 大変財産的には損し
知識的にも損でしょうし
我々には計算してみるともう恐ろしい
財産なくなっているんです
そういうわけで 殺生よりはかなり重い罪になるんです
次に心の行為 心の行為の中でミスがありまして
そのミスは一番重い罪なんです
心でただ非論理的に怒っているだけで
でもそれがものすごい罪なんです
別に私は誰にも悪いことしてないんではないかと
特に精神異常者たちがいるでしょう
すごい怒りで 憎しみで
もうもうそういう妄想ばっかりしていて
まあその人はものすごい危険なことばっかり考えているんだけど
まあ別にもう問題ない人やとかね
と思っても 本人がもうずっと罪を犯してるんですよ
そこで 世間から見れば
この人は精神的にちょっと異常であると
だから罪を問えないんだと
まあしょうがないんだと
責任はないんだと 精神異常者に人を殺されたっても
その人は裁判で自分が精神的に精神鑑定を受けてもらって
それで無罪になる しかし
仏教は違います それはもう宇宙的に人間と個人という考え方は全て法則で考えると
法則でできている組織を通して考えちゃうと
もうどうにもならんと
この組織が機能している方法が悪いんだよと
罪は罪なんです たとえ精神的な異常者が人殺したっても
これが普通の人の人殺しよりは罪が重いんです
普通の人っていうのは
もう何か訳があって殺しちゃうんですよ
なんかそのわけ聞いちゃうと
まあなるほどなという気持ちにもならないわけでもないんですよ
パレスチナ人がこの自爆テロ起こしても
10人  15人とか もうまあそんなに殺してないんで
まあ殺してはいるんですけど
やっぱりその人々の生活を見てみると
まあそれしか道がないんだからね
自分で平和で独立して
自分の国で生活 自分の国で生活するために
それしかないということにももうあるんでしょうし
ですから まあなんとなくちょっと言えない状態もあるんです
確かに イスラエル人がずっとパレスチナ人を攻めることにしたっても
その人はずっとテロでこれを脅かしてるんだから
やっぱり行って攻撃したくなるっていう気持ちも理解できないわけでもないんですね
ですから 普通の人の人殺しっていうのは
何か考えてみればそういうわけかと
異常者の人殺しはどういう風に説明すればいいんですかね
別にもう敵を探して殺したわけでもないでしょうに
だから罪がないっていうのはどういうわけですかね
突然家から出て行って
道路に歩いてる人を 2
3人刺し殺すと その人も罪がないんだと
精神的に不安定だからと
自分の土地も財産も自由ももう水まで奪われているパレスチナ人が自爆テロしたらとんでもないことだと
というのはどういう理屈か
それはもう世の中の理屈で
まあ仏教から見れば まあ人殺しは誰でも悪いんですけど
やっぱりこの怒りと欲で精神的な異常を起こしてやってる行為っていうのは
ものすごい罪が重いということになっているんです
そこで精神的に異常者っていうのは
まあ病気は病気なんですけど
それはこちら知ったことじゃないんですよ
みんなそれぞれ生命は自由だから
こちらで許してあげたっても
こちら神様ではないんだから
宇宙法則ですから だから異常になったのは何なのかと
なんでノーマルで生活しないんですかと
それはそちらの組織とその周りの環境から生まれてくる結果なんですよ
親の育て方が悪かったとかいろいろあるかもしれませんしね
だからかわいそうですよ
結局は 環境が悪かって
親の育て方も悪かっちゃ悪くなって
それで異常 精神的な異常になってしまったと
本当はもともともそういう人々は種持ってるんですよ
親に殴られたんだからって
すべての子供たちが不良になるわけないでしょうに
親に散々いろんなこと言われたんだと
そんなのはもう もうそっちが悪いことなんですよ
時々まあ男は逃げてしまったと
それで子供は精神的に異常になるとかね
まあ例えば日本のケース見ると
でお母さんと付きっきりでもう育てたんだから
そういう風に引きこもりになって
それから異常を犯したんだそう
それでそれはもう男に男が逃げてしまったんだから
言ったっても世界でそんなことっていうのはもう日常茶飯事であるでしょうに
アメリカなんか見たらもうほとんどの家族
もう男たち逃げてるんですけど
でもその人々もしっかりとすくすくと成長しますよ
ですから そこはもう時々夫婦がものすごく仲良くしているのに
子供が異常者がいるんだから
やっぱり自分でその種持ってるんですよ
その種に周りから水と栄養が入ると
もうぼんぼんと成長する
確かに種を持っていても
周りから水と栄養がくれないと
まあ芽が出ないで済む場合はあります
そういうことですから
まあやっぱり罪は罪ということになってしまうんですね
だからそこら辺でもう俗世間から見るとこんな話納得いかないんだと
私の頭が悪いと思うかもしれませんだけどね
私はまあ 私の頭が悪いかもしれませんだけど
私はお釈迦様のもう世界を紹介しているだけで
皆様の世間の頭がすごく素晴らしいんですけど
いくら経典読んでも このお釈迦様の世界は発見できんですね
それは頭が良さすぎだからなんです
ですから ある程度で私ぐらい頭が悪ければ
まあお釈迦様の世界は発見できるとも思います
それでこの何言いたいというか
やっぱりかわいそうなんですよ
ライオンは獲物を取らなくちゃいけない
でもお前罪を犯してるんだよと
そんなこと言ったって
私はもう草食べられませんと言っても効きません
そんなことは 罪は罪だと
お前に食べられるために鹿が子供育てるわけじゃないんだよと
同じことで精神異常者にしても
妄想ばっかりで 人間見ると鬼で獣で見えてしまう
それで本人が獣殺しちゃうんですね
実際はそちら人間殺してるんですね
でもあんたは人殺したと
人殺しの場合も 親殺すことはものすごい重罪で
ものすごい極力な重罪なんです
それで精神異常者が勘違いして
自分の親見たら獣やと思って
もう殺してしまう それで話して
私は親を殺してないんだと
親のこと大事に思ってるんだよと
何だと？獣が来たんだよと
私を攻撃するために そこの獣やっつけたんだよと言っても
殺したの親だから 親殺しなんですよ
罪は軽くないんです そこでもう明確にあります
書いてます それはもうどうせすごい明確に教えているのはこの出家のためなんです
一般の人々にはそんな道徳わかるわけないんですから
まあ一応言わない 言わないんですけど
出家の世界ではもうもう厳密に微妙なところまで
この道徳の世界っていうのはね
説明するんですよ テキストもかなりあるんです
面白いことは翻訳もあるんだけど
読んでもわからないことなんです
そう簡単にはね まあ他人にわかるわけじゃないんですよ
やっぱりブッダの世界に入ってないと
そう簡単ではないんです
まあ一応そこまで考えると何か結論が見えるはずなんですよ
なんか納得いかない 納得いかんですよ
例えば精神的な病気でもう弱くて
どうも何にもできない
もう妄想しかない人が
もうその人を殺さてもまあしょうがないと思って
もう何かの施設に入れておくとかね
その方がいいんではないかと
人間がそのぐらいでいいんですけど
人間が決めることじゃないんだから
道徳は神様が決めるわけじゃないんだから
これ宇宙法則だから 宇宙法則によってその人はもう人殺しで
もう重い罪 普通の人よりも罪が重いと
例えばすごい知識のある普通の人が人を殺したりする
精神的な異常者も人を殺したりする
それで二人で地獄に行ったら
一番重く裁く裁かれるのは精神異常者なんです
だからそれはもう判断して
自動判断だから すべて因果法則だからね
もうドーンと落ちてしまう
あるいは正気な人には立ち直る見込みはいくらでもあります
償うということはいくらでもできます
反省するということはいくらでもできます
こんな罪を犯しちゃったんだから
とことんこれから良い人間になってやるぞと思って
無数に大量に無制限に善行為することもできます
そうすると 善行為の重さでもう優れちゃうんですよ
あの罪は でも異常者は全くできんでしょうね
善政も反省も何もない
立ち直る方法もできない
ということで かわいそうに罪が重くなる
このかわいそうなところ
この納得いかんところは
お釈迦様が明確にハイライトしたがっているポイントなんです
残酷だと 人間だけの次元で考えるなよと
人間が勝手に恣意的に作っている社会組織の中で決まる中で考えるなよと
生きることっていうのは
もうこの上ない もうとてつもない残酷なことで
もう納得いかないことで恐ろしいことである
そういうわけで このくだらん屁理屈で出したっても
僕は全然気にしないんです
で そこの残酷さ 納得いかないこと
ちょっとした失敗で恐ろしく不幸になってくること
なんでそこまでというふうに
そういうふうに智慧のある人がありのままに見るならば見られるんだと
その人が生きることにもう厭うんだと
何の意味もないんだと
こんなに執着してやるもんじゃないんだと
蛇の遺体見たのを見たごとく
蛇の遺体を自分の首にかけたのように
あるいは鎖かけてもう膿が出ている
もう人間の遺体を自分の体にずっと顔に合わせて結んであげたような感じで
足と手と合わせて結んでおけば
歩ければ行動はしますけど
でも空気を吸うたびに遺体のあれ吸わなくちゃあかんでしょうし
どこへ行っても運ばなくちゃあかんでしょうし
それぐらいもう輪廻に対してこの嫌悪感を結んだよと
それが解脱の世界なんです
そうすると解脱しなくちゃいけない
この残骸というね 欲界
色界 無色界と残骸そのもの
全部もう恐ろしく燃えている火事のように感じると
溶岩でできている海のように感じるんだと
で そこら辺は皆様には関係ない世界かもしれませんですけど
一応仏教というのは悟りの世界ですから
そういうふうにも見ています
そういうわけで 十善十悪の場合も
この心の行為が一番重くて
罪が重くて一番恐ろしい
避けなくちゃいけない行為なんです
非論理的な怒りと非論理的な欲と邪見ということ
で 私はものすごくこの理性ちょっと失っちゃうと
みんなの話やら説明やら
ほんのちょっとでもですね
私はものすごいもう反発するでしょうに
それでも私がおかしいとみんな思ってるんですけど
私はおかしくないと自分で勝手に思ってるんですけど
わずかでも理性失うともう我慢できないんですよ
屁理屈言っちゃうと いきなりもう攻撃して潰して
もう二度ともう考えられないようにしてあげたいんですよ
これからあんた考えない方がいいやと
それぐらいもう攻撃したくなる
なぜならば これ邪見だから
見方がおかしいんだから
ちょっとした遊びで話し合いだったら別にどうったことはないんですけど
あるいは腰抜けだったら
ああ そうですね そういうふうにも考えられますよと
また 他の人が何か言ったら
ああ そうですね そういうふうにも考えられます
それでできますけど だってどんなことでも考えられますから
それは智慧の生き方じゃないんですよ
理性っていうのはすごい大事なことなんです
だから邪見は罪の中で一番大きな罪で
それでこの この7歳8歳ぐらいのその子供にお釈迦様がもう最後にこの思考についても同じ方程式で
今まで説明した同じ方程式で道徳を語っているんですね
だから心の道徳 心の道
心の思考の道徳 まあ考えただけだからいいんじゃないかということは
仏教は全然認めない それはやるよりは恐ろしいんだよと
何かやる場合でも まず考えているんだから
だから考え方を直さないとどうにもならないんですよ
人が悪口言うのも考えてから言うんですよ
人殺しでも盗むことでも
まず考えてから盗むんですよ
だから全ての罪を犯す
全ての罪を実現する原因が邪見にあるんですよ
思考にあるんです だから張犯人が真犯人が思考なのに
なぜ思考自体が甘く見るんですかね
それが仏教から見ればおかしいと思うんですよ
本当の犯人が思考だから
だから思考はしっかりしなさいと
遊ぶなよと思考と という態度をとってます
それでマナサーカンマンカットゥカーモーホーティ
もし心で何か行為をしたくなる場合はと
それが言葉が前と同じセットで言ってますから
こういう風になってますが
普通の訳は もしあなたが何か考えたいと思ったならばということなんですね
タデーワマノーカンマンパッチウィッティタッバン
この考えたがるこの対処
その概念について観察するべきですよ
考える前に ヤンヌコーアハンイダンマナサーカンマンカットゥカーモー
イダンメーマノーカンマンアッタッビアバーヤピサンワッテイヤ
パラッビアバーダーヤピサンワッテイヤ
ウバヤッビアバーダーヤピサンワッテイヤ
だからまず考える ヤンヌコーアハンイダンマナサーカンマンカットゥカーモー
私は今 心で何かこういう考えをと思ってますけど
もしそのことを考えたならばということで
もしこのことを考えたならばアッタッビアバーダーヤピサンワッテイヤ
私の破壊に 私の不幸になるかもしれません
パラッビアバーダーヤサンワッテイヤ
私には関係ないんだけど
他人の不幸に 他人の破壊になってしまうかもしれません
あるいはウバヤッビアバーダーヤピサンワッテイヤ
あるいは私の破壊にもなって
他人の破壊にもなる行為であるかもしれません
その場合はアクサランイダンマノーカンマ
このマノーカンマ この心の行為は
いわゆるこの思考がアクサラン不善であると判断するべきですね
ドゥククドリアンドゥッカヴィパーカン
苦しみは増える 苦しみの結果になる
苦しみが増える 苦しみの結果になる不善行為だよと判断すべきですと
まだやってないんです
まだ考えてない 考える前に
結果はどんな結果になる思考でしょうかと
サチートランラーフルエワンパッチエクマエワンジャーネーヤスイ
そこでそうやって観察したところで
あなたはこれを発見する
やっぱりこの思考がもう自分の破壊にもなる
他人の破壊になる あるいは自分と他人の両方の破壊になる
自分だけの破壊になるか
他人だけの破壊になるか
自分と他人の両方の破壊になるか
どちらかでしょう そう分かったら
エワンピテーラーフルマナサーカンマンササッカンナカラニーヤ
絶対するべきではありません
ササッカンナカラニーヤ
絶対考えてはいけません
そんなことは 思考自体にストップかけなさいと
そこでまた観察すると
このこれから考えようとしているものがどんなものかなと考えたら
自分の不幸になるものでもないし
他人の不幸になるものではないし
自分と他人と両方の不幸になるものでもありませんとわかったならば
それが善行為であると
それで幸福になるものであると見えると
その場合はクサランイダンマノーカンマンスクドリアンスクイパーカンというところがあります
この 418 ページの一番最後の行
で それから 19 ページの一行目でエワルーパンテーラーフルマナサーカンマンカラニーヤ
そのような心の思考をやりなさいよと
なぜならば これは幸福になる思考ですから
考えてもいいんじゃないかと
で それが行為をする前の段階ですから
判断ミス犯す可能性ありますよ
まだやってないんだから
結果がわからないんですね
次に考えるんですよ 良い行為だけ考える
良い行為だけ考えるんだけど
考えてる最中でも道徳判断を行ってみるんですよ
いつでもこれがいいものか悪いものか
いいものか悪いものか
ずっとその観察を持っていかなくちゃいけないんです
考えてる最中でも こんなことを考えたら
私のためになるんでしょうかね
こんなことを考えたら
人のためになるんでしょうかね
私たちみんなのためになるものかなと
ずっと考えてる最中でも
やらなくちゃいけない
なぜならば 考える前の判断に
もしかすると判断ミスがある可能性あります
やってないことの場合は単なる過程だけでしょうに
やってるとわかるんですよ
うまくいってるかないかっていうことは
ですから やってる最中でも判断して
やってる最中でやっぱりこれがいいと思ってやっているんだけど
やってみると悪いんだとわかったら
すぐその場でやめる 判断した瞬間でそれをやめてもらう
それで行為をやってる最中でもいい行為だ
いい行為だと判決が出たならば
終わりまでやっちゃうでしょ
それで終わらないんですよ
一旦やって終わってから
またこの過去の行為をまた観察する
そうすると一番正しい判断が出てくるんですよ
もうデータがあるんだから
ある思考をしました その結果としてこの結果が出たんだよと
もう結果もあるんだから
もう過去のものだから
もう変わらないんだから
それできちんとこの行為とこの結果がよりどんなものかと判断できる
ですから こちらで何行目からでしたっけ
大体真ん中の辺り 過去形のものが出てくるんですね
真ん中の辺りと言っても
この上から数えると十八行目かな
カッワピテーラーホレマナサーカッマンということ
カッワピテーラーホレマナサーカッマンタデーワテーマノカッマンパッチウェッキタッバン
カッワピ やってからでもやって終わった
やったことは悪いことじゃないんですよ
良いと判断したものをやったんですよ
やってる最中でも判断したんです
それでいつでもマルが出たんですよ OK
が出たんです いいことだ
いいことだと やりなさいと OK
が出たものをやっちゃったんですよ
やって終わってからカッワピテーラーホレマナサーカッマン
やって終わってからでもまた観察するべきですね
どのように観察するかというと
私は心でこういう行為をしましたと
それは私のためになったんでしょうか
あるいは他人のためになったんでしょうか
あるいは両方のためになったんでしょうかと
それで観察してみるんですね
なったんでしょうかと観察するだからしっかりした観察もできるし
しっかりした道徳判決もできるんですね
そこでやっぱり良いと思ってやったのに
やる前にも考えたら良いことだなとわかったのに
やってる時でも考えたんですけど
いいことだなと思って考えたのに
考えて終わってしまったら
何か悪いこと考えちゃったんではないかと
判決出たら それは下から計算する
九番目の行の真ん中から
エーワルーペーテーラーホレマノカッメアッティーヒタッバンハラーイタッバン
もしやって終わってから
やっぱりまずかったとわかったら
アッティーヒタッバンハラーイタッバン
ものすごく嫌うべきですよと
ああ 悪いこと ものすごい嫌なこと
悪いことやってしまったと
考えていいことだとやったのに
やっぱりまずかったと
良くないことをやってしまったと
ものすごく嫌悪感というかね
嫌なことをしてしまったというふうに
その気持ちを作らなくちゃいけないんだと
アッティーヒトハラーイトゥワジグチットワアーティンサンワリンサンワランアーパッチタッバン
二度と アーヤティンというのは二度としないサンワラン
コントロールする 制御する
自己管理する アーヤティンというのはこれからですね
これからはということで自分を自己管理しなさいと
終わったことはしょうがないんだから
それがもう悪いと 良くない
汚い 醜いと判断しておく
堂々と判断する それでそれが反省ということなんです
しょうがなく悪いことをしたんだということはとんでもない罪なんです
いい悪いことをしちゃったんだと
汚い 醜い 恐ろしいことをしてしまったと
と そのまま受け止めることが反省になるんであって
でもしょうがなかったんだよと言ったら反省にならない
また取り消しになっちゃうんです
正当化したんだというと
罪がまた倍になっているんです
犯した罪が一つなのに
もう認めながら正当化しちゃうと
もうはい倍ですよ ということになる
だから 汚い 醜い 恐ろしい
恥ずかしいことをやったよと思って恥を感じると
もう二度とやれないんですよ
二度とやる気にはなりません
もうひどい醜い恥ずかしい目にあったんだから
気持ちとして二度と同じ思いをしたくないでしょうね
それが反省なんです 二度とやりたくないってことは
二度とやれないことはね
ですから 本当に悪いことをしました
すみませんでしたと謝る人っているでしょうね
だからえらい気持ち悪いんですよ
反省しているかないかすぐわかるんだから
ずっと謝るばっかしの人生でね
それでよくよく見ると同じことなんですよ
別なことで謝るんだったら別にどうったことないんだけど
同じもう失敗で一生謝って謝って
はいはいわかりましたと
で またまた同じこと あ
すみませんでした また同じく
そんな反省でも何でもないんですよ
そこら辺でも 例えば日本の社会の思考と仏教の社会の思考っていうのはものすごい違うとは思います
反省で言ったっても もうそれも厳しい
とにかく これは自己反省であって
もう他人に仏教も他人に言うことはもう他人に言いなさいと
自分の目の上の人にちゃんと言いなさいと
懺悔しなさいということをはっきりしていますけど
この経典でもいつでも懺悔しなさい
懺悔しなさいと だから目の上の人に
先生に懺悔する場合ははっきりと表すことであって
先生にもとことん叱れますよ
すごい恥かちゃうんですよ
その人に あ いい子だいい子だ
もう悪いことをわかったんだから
本当にあんたいい子だねと
それって言わない 先生も
とてつもなく恥かちゃうんです
そうしちゃうと 弟子がもう二度と懺悔はしたくないということになっちゃうんです
こんなに恥かかられるんだったらということで自分を戒めるんです
もう二度とはやりません
それで仏教の世界で もう二度と懺悔しないで逃げ隠れできるかというと
これは無理 サンガの生活だから個人プライバシーはない
サンガの中では やること誰ににもチェックできる権利があります
年上であろうが下であろうが全然関係ない
年上の人が悪いことをやったら
年下の人に権利があるんです
チェックしてこれ悪いんだよ
お前なんか何ですか？出て行けと言ったら
その場合は年下だから出て行くんだけど
サンガが集まるときは報告する
サンガの前で そうするともうサンガの権利っていうのは絶対的権利で
どうにもならんですよ
お釈迦様は自分よりも絶対的権利サンガに与えて亡くなったんです
全部サンガでグループで決めますと
その決まりは誰にも変えることはできません
個人でどう頑張っても
決めた法律を解除することできるのはサンガでサンガですよと
ですから サンガの決まりっていうのは
お釈迦様の言葉と同じく
絶対的な力を持っているんです
だから誰でもすごく怖いんです
例えば自分の先生をお寺から出て行けと言ったら
先生と喧嘩したってもいいんです
出て行ってと言っても出て行きませんよとかね
それで弟子弟子が性格があまりにも悪くて
先生にも手に負えない場合は
先生が月二回ぐらい集まりますからね
サンガの前でこの弟子が決まり守れませんよと報告しますとサンガに報告しますと言っちゃうと
それでもう終わり どうにもならん
それでサンガが調べて
ちゃんと弁解する権利を与える
弁解します 弁解したところで
しかしあんたはこういう戒律破っている
こういう決まり破っている
こういう決まり破っているという故に
あなたは出て行くことを決めますよと言ったら
もう終わり もう出て行くしか何のこともできません
個人で言われたらもう喧嘩したっても別に個人のことだからね
だからサンガの決まりはもう破れません
どれほどサンガの決まりが厳しいかというと
この阿羅漢になっている阿羅漢たちが禅定能力もあると体も心もストップするんですね
瞑想で 心は機能しない
それを何日間いられます
体も機能しない 完全停止
普通の人から見れば死んでいると
でも死んではない なぜならば死んだ遺体だったら腐りますからね 2
日目で膨らみますからね
それはない そのままで体があるんです
しかし 呼吸もしていない
呼吸していないんだから心臓も動いていない
だから血液も流れない
しかし 血液は固めません
流れない血液は固めるようになってますけど
固めません そういうものすごい普通には理解できないことですけども
簡単ではないんですけど
阿羅漢でないとできません
煩悩は全部なくなってないとは禅定に入ることはできません
それでそれでサマーディ瞑想の訓練も必要なんです
かなりの技なんです それに入っていても
サンガが命令するとすぐ自分のサマーディが壊れるんですよ
それぐらいサンガの命令が力強いんです
例えば集まるところである阿羅漢がいて
もう禅定に入っていて
もう集まれないんですよ
そこで集まらなくなってもいいんですけど
阿羅漢だからね 別に賛否すること何もないし
しかし何か問題が起きたりします
これ困ったなと これはもう判決できんと
あのお坊さんが必要やと言ったら
その場でサンガはもうなんとかのお坊さんはサンガに参加することは命じますとという決まり出すんですよ
その決まりが有効 決まったということになると
あのア羅漢に禅定に入っているお坊さんの心がパッと戻って
体が機能し始めるんですよ
禅定からもう覚める 目覚めるんです
目覚めたらなんで目覚めたんですかと
自分の決まったことと違うんではないか
やっぱりこれはもう明らかにサンガの命令だとわかる
すぐ参加するんです で
どういうことですかと
それぐらいもうサンガの力っていうのはもうすごいもんです
それは仏教の世界でね
仏教と以外の人々には関係ないことだけどね
で 私たちにとっては それはものすごいもう大変な力なんです
嘘でも何でもない どうしても乗り越えられない
どんな人でも誰でもその前では無能になっちゃうんです
そこでだからでサンガサンガにサンガ集めていい加減なことできるかというと
それはできません サンガにもちゃんと憲法というものがあるんだから
その憲法を破すことはできません
だからすごい この法律みたいなノウハウっていうのは
出家する人にとってはかなりあるんですよ
だから年間の修行させ
訓練させるんだからね
この年間弟子入りするということは
この法律の関係のですよ
ということで 結構いろんな頭が鋭くなる勉強っていうのはいくらたくさんあります
うん まあそういうことですから
このとにかく懺悔しなくちゃいけない
懺悔しちゃうと当然もう侮辱
侮辱ではなくて恥かけられます
これうまくできてます
で 沙弥の場合でも同じことをやるんですよ
沙弥は比丘ではないんだから
比丘の集まりには入れません
追い出しも入れません
しかし 沙弥も見習いだから
一人前の比丘になる訓練はしなくちゃいけない
そこでどうせ子供たちでしょうし
初心者でしょうし あれこれやと間違いはする
間違いするたびに先生が「これはもうダメ」という風に言って
また戒律をもう最初からやり直せちゃう
これもある程度で恥ずかしいんですよ
あなたの沙弥出家また新しく戒律をするぞと
決まりとしては本当は月一回やらなくちゃいけない
それにしたっても それもちょっとした恥ずかしいことですから
すごい尊いこととしてはやっています
それでもちょっといたずら好きで
もうちょっと男たちですから
ほとんどね もう言うことを聞かないっていうのは決まってるし
何かやめなさいと言ったらまた何かやってしまっちゃうし
それは子供の性格だからね
それは知っているし その場合は君に罰を与えるんだよと
で 罰がいくつか決まってるんですね
10種類の 決まり破ったら罰を与える
例えばお坊さんたちに向かって口利いちゃうと
一つ罰なんです いくつかあります
そこで罰として だいたい水汲みとかね
まあそんなもんですけど
あるいはこの仏塔とかそういうところに砂を運ぶこととかね
砂を運んでそこら辺は綺麗にしなさいとかね
そういうことをする するんですね
砂を運びなさいと言ったら
寺のあるところにある砂を持って運んだらダメなんです
外から運ばなくちゃいけないんです
そこで川とかそういうところに行って
自分で砂を持ってきて運ぶんです
運ぶ時は もし誰かが「何でお坊さん何やってるんです？」と聞いたら言わなくちゃいけないんです
例えば「あのね あの あの
あのブッダ寺のところはちょっと石
小石がいっぱいあるんだから
私はちょっと砂をかけてるんだ」と言ったら格好いいでしょう
それが禁止なんです 「
寺を綺麗にするのは寺にいる者の仕事ではないか」と言っちゃうと
それが禁止で 全部何で運んでいるかと言わなくちゃいけないんです
実は罰を決められたんだと
何ででしょうかと聞いたら
本当はこういうことをしちゃったんだよと
これはおばあさん聞いても言わなくちゃいけないんですよ
同じ年の子供たちが聞いて
何でお坊さんそれって言わなくちゃいけないんですよ
これすごい恥ですよ だからそういう風に一応昔の
昔の決まり 今はもうほとんどやったことも見たこともないんですけど
一応私は昔の人間で育てられたんだから
一応こういうことだよとは言ってくれるんですよ
私の長老ももう結構砂を運んだよとかね
というと それは私に対しての脅しなんですね
まあそういうことで 未然にあの
まあ戒めることはできるようになるんです
ですから もう恥をかけるということは
もう徹底的にやるっていうのを
仏教の世界のやり方なんですね
そういう風に とにかく人を育てるんですよ
こんな腰抜けの人っていうのはもう
もう育てません 大物を育てるんです
何にもめげない すごい正直で
自分に厳しくて 善悪判断しっかりできる
人格者を育てるんですよ
だからこの格の一番低い
この社会に出ることもできない人でも
出家して一人前になったら堂々と童児でね
王様にでも説法する 王様でもないからそれがどうでしょうかと言えるぐらいすごい人格っていうのが出てくるんです
だからそこでまあこの人格形成の世界ですからね
で 悪いこと何もない純粋な性格で
それでしっかりしていると
欲も怒りも高慢も何一つもない
しかし心がすごく強い
でもわがままではありません
という理想的な完璧な人間っていうのは作る世界です
そういう風に この心で何か行為をしたならば
心でこうして何か考えたならば
だからみんなすごくもうすごくいい加減で好き勝手で変なことを考えているでしょうね
それは仏教から見ればとんでもない危険なことなんですよ
くだらんことを考えないでと
その時間無駄ですよ どれほど妄想するために時間かかるかというと
もう仕事に使う時間っていうのはほんのわずかでしょうに
ずっとあれこれあれこれと
もうトンチンカンなことばっかり考えてる
だからもう何をしてなくても
思い存分罪を犯してますよ
そこで仏教に笑っちゃっても不幸でしょうに
結局はもう不幸で生きていられない
食べていられない状態でしょうに
何のことなく この野生の鳥のように何の心配することもなく生活できますよ
人間には これがもう頭の中でももう 24時間も罪を犯している
それやめてみれば そうすると無駄無駄なことを考えない場合は
何か考えるならば有効なこと
必要なことしか考えないでしょうに
それでどれほど頭が良くなることもいますかね
どれほど鋭くなることもいますかね
だから私にしたって もうこの恥かける文化に育てられたんだから
本当にもう言いたくはなりますよ
だから違う異文化の世界にいるんだから
もうもう我慢して我慢して我慢して
もうもうどうにもならなくて嫌になっちゃうんですね
結局は 喋ってはあかんと思うところほど
一言葉では言えますよ
もうくだらんことを言うと
もうあんた言ってるのはこういうことではないかと
それでこの 思考の無駄っていうことに例なんですけど
ある人からメール来たんですね
そこにあったのはものすごくよく考えて書いてるみたいですけど
本人は 生きることはドゥッカであるならば
子供を育てたら 産んだならば
その子供はもうずっと一生死ぬまで苦しまなくちゃいけないんだと
ですから 子供を作ることは罪ではないかと
それについてあなた方の上座仏教はどう考えているんでしょうかという
この態度とかね えらい仏教っていうのはゴキブリ扱いされて
自分たちがすごい尊い思考を持ってるんだから
私たちの思考の失敗をね
偉そうに生きることはドゥッカやと言うんですけどね
あなた方は矛盾じゃないかという態度でね
それで面白いことは もう会員でもよく勉強する人々でしょうにね
他の人に質問しませんだからね
それで試しにその時いた人々に私は聞いたんです
あんたならどう答えるんでしょうかとかね
みんなもうもうそうしっかりしているんだと OK
やと見ているんですね
その論理は まあまあ勉強の程度それぐらいですからね
ですから これはもう誰にも任すわけに
大体質問ぐらいはもう自分たちで答えたってもね
仏教を勉強してるんだったら
私はどうってことないと思いますけど
これは任すわけにはいきません
私も一応返事書いたんですね
お返事の中でもげんとね
で もう書いて書いて いわゆるまあ生命誕生することを生命面倒見るから
それは悪やということは
あなたは生きていることが悪だと思ってるんだよと
という論理をもうちょっと延長して考えると
今生きている人でもそれで殺してしまえば
その人の苦しみが減るんだと
という論理で言葉違うと思いますけど
一回書いたものっていうのは綺麗に忘れちゃいますから
私は でないと頭が腐っちゃうんですよ
で また読み直さないと何書いたかと覚えてない
一応論理のシステムだけは覚えてますね
ですから わかりやすく言えば
歳 の寿命のある人が今歳だったら
その人歳で殺してしまえば年間の苦しみが減るんですよ
すごい論理的だからね
だから子供を産まないことだけではなくて
生きている人々にも寿命が縮み
死にあげればみんなの苦しみが減るんです
すごい戦後ですよ それで
もっと延長して考えれば
今作っている原子爆弾なんか全部一斉に爆破してもらって
地球上のすべての生命が消えてもらったら
一発ですべての苦しみが終わるんだと
あんた言ってるのはそういうことよ
だからそれは明らかに仏教から見ればとてつもない想像できんほどの邪見やと
だから軽々く良さそうに見えたんだからといって思考とは遊ぶなよと
だから思考も中途半端でしょうね
あの人の なんで考えることは綺麗にまとめるところまで考えないんですかね
まとめるところまで考えたら
もうとてつもない もうもう究極な生命の殲滅を唱え唱えていることになっちゃうんですよ
お釈迦様時代でも 弟子の中でもう人いたんだから
同じこと言ってる それと一つのポイントで
ですから この仏教から見れば
生まれる来る人は自分の責任で生まれるんであって
人間には子供を作るということはできるわけじゃないでしょうし
たとえ試験管で合わせたっても
誕生するかないかということはもう知ったもんじゃないんですよ
精子と卵子と合わせたんだからといって
確実に生命が誕生するということがないでしょうに
だから今試験管の場合でも
やっぱり卵子 たくさん取っちゃいますよ
そんなたくさんはないんですけど
やっぱりもう一応取れるもの全部取っちゃうんですよ
そこで大量の精子を入れちゃって合わせちゃうんです
だから試験管で子供を作る
大体まあニサン匹ぐらい生まれますよ
それで余計なものを処分して
一つ選んで またお腹に植えて植える
植えますけど そんなにしっかりできるんだったら
一つだけ生命を作ればいいでしょうに
そんな無理 たとえ試験管の場合でも
だからそれがどこかの生命が宿らない限りは生命にはならない
だから生まれてくる人っていうのは自分勝手で生まれているんであって
誰にもいちいち文句言う権利はないんですよ
親が悪かったとかね 貧しい家庭で生まれたとか
きつい酷い環境で生まれた
あんたの責任でしょうと
それはどう どううまく生活するかって
これは自分の判断でしょうね
私に至ってもすごい貧しい家庭で生まれたんですけど
それでずっともう大学卒業する時でも
もうろくに食べたことはない
本を買ったことはない
紙なんかはもう 3枚  4枚とか
それしか買わないんですよ
授業に行く前にあの授業だったら 4枚必要やとか
それで裏と表でぎっしり書く小さな文字で
そういう風に勉強してたんですよ
一言も親に文句言ったことはないんです
鉛筆 1つ買ってくれと家にいる時でも頼んだことはないんです
全部あっちこっちみんな捨てるものとかね
もらって 自分が堂々としてたんで
誰にもいじめられたことでもないし
学校でも王様気分でいましたし
自分の仕事をちゃんとやるんだから
先生たちにはとことん可愛がってもらったし
テキストはないでしょうに
全然不自由ではなかったんです
ササッと他の子供たちがテキスト持って
はいはい 見て見てと  2人で見ましょうと
なぜかというと こちらも自分の仕事ちゃんとやってるんだから
その人にとっては私に見せることでえらい得があるんです
だって教えてあげるんだから
だから今も誰にももう頭下げませんし
手も出せませんし 自分のことは自分の責任やと
だから生まれてきたのは自分の責任で
もしかすると私の人格形成にはぴったし合う親を選んで生まれたと思いますよ
それ自分の業だから もし間違ってでも日本みたいに咲かぬ生まれた
もう何の光も何もない
もうただの動く生ゴミで生きていることになるでしょうに
まあ地球でどこでも生きていられます
誰でも出てこいと 文句でもあったら
だからまあ まずやっぱり自分が自分の人生をどう形成するかっていうことは
あくまでも自分の責任であって
ですからそこは難しいと
そこはその人に変えてないんですけど
だから生まれてきたっていうことは
そのその生命の責任なんですよ
親のあれあれやということじゃないんですよ
親が一生懸命勝手に入ったから人の面倒見てあげるんだから
ブッダは感謝しなさいと
捨てないで育てたんだから
だからですよ 仏教は徹底的に親にはもう感謝するしかもう感謝しなさい
親に何されたって もう感謝しなさい
あれほど愛してるんだから
その裏にあるのは 個人個人が別々な生命であるという論理なんですよ
全くも他人だと 全くの他人なのに
自分の命よりも大事にして育てるということ
これがとんでもない恩返ししないと
今更なんで親をそんなに尊敬しなくちゃあかんかと言ったっても
仏教の世界の思考はそういう思考なんです
そこで業は認めませんし
何も認めませんという
それだったら話になりませんだからね
何も認めませんというのは
それは一番頭の悪い人に一番簡単に言えることで
わかりません だから認めませんと
そんなのは神様の気分で言うことですよ
わかりませんゆえに認めませんというのは
全てが私はわかっているんだよという態度でしょうに
我々を知っているのはほんのわずかでしょうに
知っていることと知らないことというのは比べられないでしょうに
地球の大きさと この空気に飛んでいる塵ひとつぐらいなものでしょうに
自分知っているものを
それで私が知らないんだから認めないという態度というのは
もう明らかにこの神様気分でしょう
だから そういう風に人がもう喋るのは喋るんだけど
知識そうに知識そだと言いたいんですけどね
本当もうおかしくてもうたまらんですよ
だからそういうのは我々仏教的に今いっぱいつり恥かけちゃうと
もう二度と変な思考をしないんですよ
だからその人にとってはすごく役に立つんですよ
罪を犯させずに済むんですよ
それで私の言葉とは言い方に
もう道徳的に教えてあげようとおせっかいしようとするんだからね
損するのは私ではありませんしね
言わせた方がいいと思いますけどね
だからこのきついとか痛いことっていうのは
もうただ行儀悪いんだから言ってるんじゃなくて
もう計算しながら言ってるんです
嫌な気持ちにさせると
恥かけると だからまあそこら辺もそれもすごい難しい仕事をできれば皆さんはやってみてください
どれほど難しいかと ただ見栄を張って恥かけることできるんだけど
すごい鋭く知恵で考えて計算してできるかと
そうできることというのは
ものすごい難しい仕事なんです
では このそのケースの場合でもね
まあそういうことを書いても
最終的にちょっとした
このまあもうちょっとしたこのスパイスみたいね
一言入れたんですよ もう仮にあなたの思考は正しいと見ても
本当はまあ人間に性行為するなかれということではないかと
性行為するんだから子供が生まれるんだから
それでこの世の中の人々には
あらゆる宗教で昔からもう嘘をつくなよと言ってるんだよと
しかしみんな嘘をついてるんだよと
それぐらいのことも守ってないのに
いわゆる守られないのに
嘘つくなぐらいも人間が守られないんですよ
それで性行為するなかれという
あくまでも自然な行為をやめなさいということはできますかと
嘘をつくことは自然行為じゃないでしょうに
性行為っていうのは全く自然の行為でしょうに
変な異常現象じゃないでしょうに
そういう風になっているんだから
子供を育てるために 作るためには
まあそうやって 合わせなくちゃいけない
植物の場合でも同じこと
だから明らかな自然行為をやめなさいと言っても
人間に呼吸するなかれということと同じなんですね
だからそんな話はもう通じるでしょうかという一言は一応入れておいたんですね
でも私の おそらく私の理屈は誰も分かってないかもしれません
私のはくだらんことを言うなよということなんです
嘘つくなかれ 人殺すなかれとかね
人間は不自然的な行為をやっているのに
それをやめなさいと言っているんだけど
不自然な行為さえもやめられない弱いもんでしょうに
それで呼吸するなかれ
ご飯食うなかれとかね
性行為するなかれと そんなのは生命組織っていうのは誰でもやっていることだから
そちらで仏教が言ってるのは
その世界ででも道徳を守れということなんですよ
で もう誰がそんなことをもうやめてくれるでしょうかということで文章終わったんだけど
その読む人々はそれだけ持ってきて
ああそうには見つけたそう
じゃあ攻撃するそうと思って
全部前の頭の部分はカットして
この世の中で誰も守ってないのに
性行為するなかれと言っても何の意味もありませんというところだけ取るんですよ
どうやって では なんで上座仏教の人々はもう結婚もしないで子供育てないでいるんでしょうかと
それは矛盾ではないでしょうかとか
まあ書くは書くは どんな学校で勉強してるんですかね
見事に文章のね 途中からカットして
何様のつもりですかね
誰に向かってこの矛盾を見つけてやろうとしてるんですかね
有効な話ですかね まあこれがわからないんだよというのならばね
それなりに答えられますけどね
これはもしかすると この私の口癖
この調子に同じ調子に乗ってやろうと思うことでしょうね
これが意外に難しいと思います
この私と私が言っているように
もう一発ですぐバカにしてあげて
もうもうということは
これがもうやりたければ
もう私のところで訓練を受けることなんです
でも そう簡単に私は弟子入りはしません
私を弟子にしてくださったっても
もうそう簡単ではない
別に負けるわけじゃないんです
育てるかないかも知ってますから
だから大体近寄らない方がいいんですよ
もうすごい もうできないと思います
だから私たちが決める
この人だったらもう負けないと
だからこのサッカーのワールドカップとは違います
これ何倍も難しい  そこら辺で
まあそれは今までの説明は
まあ仏教のお釈迦様が考えている道徳の世界
それで今日は思考について考えましたけど
まあ思考は我々は智慧が開発していない限りは
やたらに思考してはいけません
何か仏教の何かちょっとちょっと拾って
それについてガチャガチャ考えたって
前の同じゴミの中で思考するんだから
邪見になる恐れがいくらでもあります
だから生きることはドゥッカであるということがいい加減に取ったところで
とんでもない邪見になってしまう
それで思考の管理っていうのは必ずしも必要です
思考の管理する方法っていうのは
お釈迦様が怒りに基づいて考えるなよと
欲に基づいて考えるなよと
考えるときはいつでも慈しみ
慈しみというところでって考えるんですよ
そうすると まあガタガタ思考でも邪見にはなりません
欲を減らす方向へ考える
もう大量に自然の資源を破壊することではなくて
もうどうすれば節約できるか
どうすれば節約できるかと
そういうふうに考えてほしいんです
科学者ももうとことん
もうもうたくさんみんな子供を産んで
動植物はいっぱいもう成長して
それでもいくらがいくら人間が増えても
もうとにかくみんなにどうすれば生活できるかと
今の思考は邪見なんですよ
一人がどれほどたくさんたくさん資源を食うかということしか考えてないでしょ
一人の人間がものすごいたくさん自然の資源を壊すことで科学発展であって
その思考というのは邪見的な思考で
一人の人が大量に電気エネルギー使うんじゃなくて
それの電気エネルギーでたくさん人々が恵み
恵みにあうようにというふうに考えなくちゃいけないんです
日本でこのガソリン １リットルの場合は５６？５３%税金だそうですね
で ５３%税金払ってガソリン１リットル買う
飲むためにミネラルウォーター１リットル買う
どちらが高いんですか？ミネラルウォーターの方が高いんですよ
ガソリン１リットルは１１０円 １２０
円あたりですからね そこでミネラルウォーター１リットルにどれぐらい税金払ってますかね
まあ我々消費税払ってますけど
会社？だからどれほどボロ儲けかということでしょうね
どれほど汚いかと この儲けのやり方という
だからそういう風な商売だからね
もう幸せになるわけじゃないし
お金が取りすぎだからもう倒産するということも決まっているし
だから思考はちょっともう整理すれば
この地球はまるっきり違う世界になるんですよ
そんなこと言ったらこの
水が買わないで生活できない国々もあります
水がない 日本ではものすごい水があるでしょう
一番と言えるほど恵まれているでしょう
それでインドネシアみたいところで
アメリカでもそうでしょうし
そうたくさん水があるわけじゃないんです
それで料理やら全部ミネラルウォーターでやってますよ
こんな値段だったらできますかね
あの大きなあれでも１０個２０個ひとつの日にで買うんですよ
これぐらい大きい それをポンと入れちゃって
そこから出して出して料理やら何でも使うし
ですから やっぱりそういうこともね
関係ないこととか みんな考えてないことだからね
まあ理解しないと思いますけど
よっぽど豊かでないとご飯はミネラルウォーターで炊けないと思いますよ
あれ２つぐらい必要ですから
やっぱり商売っていうのは悪いことじゃないんですよ
商売の場合はこれぐらいはお金かかりました
プロフィットはこれぐらいだというふうにちゃんと
論理的に決めてやるとすごくうまくいきますよ
世の中って まあとにかくこの思考自体っていうのは正しく考えなければいけない
中途半端でいろんなくだらないことも考えていけない
とにかく考える場合は
慈しみに基づいて考えた方が安全ですよ
すべての生命に役に立つ方向へ考えれば安全だっすよ
だから正思惟というね
正しい思考っていうものははっきりと釈迦様は定義してあるんです
正思惟というのはネッカンマサンカッパ
アヴィアーパーディサンカッパ
アヴィヒンサーサンカッパ
ネッカンマサンカッパっていうのは欲を減らす方向へ考える
アヴィヒンサーサンカッパっていうのは
この まあ人を暴力 いじめをしない方向へ
もう助けてあげる方向へ考える
アヴィアーパーディサンカッパって
いわゆる平和的な思考
アヴィアーパーディサンカッパというのは怒りと反対の慈しみの思考なんですね
その三つの思考でいくらでも考えられますから
それは基準だから その基準で考えてみなさいよと
誰でもすごい尊い立派な人格者になるんですよ
医学を勉強する人は その思考で勉強すると立派な医学者になる
工学の人っていうのはすごい立派な人になる
他の技術屋さんだったらすごい立派な人々になります
誰でも 思考さえ直せば
それで終了で 経典の最後ですけど
百
二十ページ  Ye keci rāhula atītana addhānaṃ samāṇavā br
āhmaṇavā kāyakammaṃ parisodhesuṃ
vācīkammaṃ parisodhesuṃ manokammaṃ parisodhesuṃ sabbe
te evaṃ meva paccavekkhitvā
paccavekkhitvā kāyakammaṃ parisodhesuṃ paccavekkhitvā paccavekk
hitvā vācīkammaṃ
parisodhesuṃ paccavekkhitvā paccavekkhitvā manokammaṃ parisodhesuṃというところ
まあ長いんだけど 訳は簡単です
ラーフラ もし過去世でアティータンアッダーナン
今ではなくて過去で サマナーワブラームナーワ
宗教家なんです シャモンたちボラモンたちっていうのは宗教たちなんですよ
カーカママンパリソーデソン
自分の体の行為を清らかにしたならば
ワチーカママンパリソーデソン
言葉を清らかにしたならば
マノーカママン 思考を清らかにしたならば
いわゆる道徳的に善行為をしたならば
サッベーテ すべての人々がエーワメーワ
このようにパッチャヴェッキットワパッチャヴェッキットワ
今まで説明した通りに観察して観察して
体の行為も言葉の行為も心の行為も綺麗にしましたよと
過去世で それから次に
エーケーチラーフラアナガタマッダーナサマナーワブラームナーワ
また同じ文章です それから将来の宗教家たちが清らかな体の行為
言葉の行為 思考は清らかなものをしたい
悪いことをしたくないと思うならば
このように観察して観察してやらなくてはならないんだと
パリソーデッサンテ 未来形でこのようにするでしょうと
それで現在 エーヒピケーチラフラエータラヒサマナーワブラームナーワ
今現在にいるシャモンバラモンたちも
カーエカママンパリソーデンティ
体のことを清らかにする
ワチーカママンパリソーデンティ
言葉を清らかにする マノーカママンパリソーデンティ
思考を清らかにする サッベーテ
みんなすべてがエーワメーワパッチャヴェッキットワ
このように観察して観察して
カーエカママンパリソーデンティ
体の行為も清らかにする
言葉の行為も清らかにする
思考も清らかにするんだよと
そのセット これはお釈迦様の言葉
言い方で 言い回しで それからパーリ語の言い回しでもあります
結構長く言っちゃうんです
こちらで結局現代風に短く言えば
これしか道がないよと
これ唯一の方法だということなんです
だから過去現在未来にしておくんです
過去の人であろうが 現在の人であろう
過去の人が善行為したというならば
この風にやるしかないよと
こういう風にやったんだよと
将来の人々は善行為してと思うならば
こういう風にやるしかないんだよと
今現在あなた方はいいことをしたいと思うならば
こういう風にやるしかないんだいということは
これしかないんだいということなんです
パッチャヴェッカナ オブザベーション
観察 三段階でやる前に
やってる時とやってからと Observation
の観察の角度が自分のためになるか
他人のためになるか 両方のためになるかというこの三つなんです
私のためになっただけで善行為ではありません
私が楽しいんだからというやることは悪なんですよ
他人のことを考えてないんだから
あるいは自分が不幸になってなって他人には幸福だったら
それも良くないんです
それ二番目 やっぱり自分も楽しく
他人も楽しくっていうことにならなくちゃいけないんです
この三番目で その三つの条件で観察するんですね
だからこれが普遍的な法則である
誰にも他の方法は語れないんだよと
これが違いますよと言える人間がいませんよと
いろんなところでお釈迦様は言ってるんです
いません で言ったってよくいることなんですけど
だからそこをちょっと見てみると
もうなんかもう面白いんですね
思考が そこでお釈迦様は結論出すんですね
ラーフラ尊者に タスマティハラーフラパッチャウェッキットワパッチャウェッキットワカーヤカッマンパリソデッサマ
自分の息子だから パリソデッサマっていうのは私たちという動詞なんですよ
ですからラーフラよく観察して観察して
体の行為を綺麗にしましょうという
息子に喋ってるんだから
命令で言ってないんですよ
だから微妙なところでそれすぐわかるんですね
普通だったらお坊さんとだったらやりなさいと
やった方がいいんだよと言うんですよ
相手が自分の息子だから
ですからね 二人で頑張ろうという気持ちなんですよ
よく観察して体の行為をしっかりしましょうと
で よく考えてパッチユキットワパッチユキットワワチーカッマンパリソデッサマ
もう言葉の行為も観察して観察して
もう直りましょう 直しましょう
で 観察して観察して考え方も直しましょうよと
やっぱり親のちゃんと役もブッダであるにも関わらず
そこら辺もやってあげるんですよ
一緒にやるとかね まあそこら辺でまあ子供すごい元気になって
まあ一緒にやるっていうことにするんですよ
イドゥマウォーチャバガヴァお釈迦様はこのように説きましたと
アッタマナアヤスマラーフルオラーフラ尊者が大変喜びましたと
バゴートウバーシタンお釈迦様の言葉を阿鼻然で
まあ喜びましたと まあ仏教の世界においては
これがすごい大変な 経典でものすごい簡単に聞こえるんだからね
ああ単純だ なんだ仏教の道徳ってそんな程度でしょうかというふうに思われてしまう可能性はありますけど
まあ仏教の世界の中では
まあそういうのは簡単ということでもないです
大変な作業なんですね
我々いうのはそう簡単には善人かぶりはできませんと
かぶりはそんなにいい言葉ではないんですけど
そう簡単には良い人間にはなれっこはないんだよと
これ大変な作業ですよ
ずっと気をつけなくちゃいけない
ということなんです で
それが大変やと言うんだったら
もう人間失格なんですよ
大変であることはもう覚悟の上で
でないとこの輪廻は脱出できません
それでスーッと瞬間瞬間もやっていることについて観察するんだったら
ものすごく鋭く頭が開発していくんですよ
これ頭の開発はもう もうどうしても必要なこと
だから智慧が宝物で智慧を目指すもので
しかし 智慧が目的でもないんですよ
智慧が土台であって 解脱するために
だから道徳判断の場合は
俗世間から見れば納得いかないこといっぱい我々言うんです
クジラは一口にたくさん魚を食べていると
トン単位で計算する まあ 1トンは食べないと思いますけど
まあ 2日間ご飯食べると 2
日 3日ご飯食べると 1トンぐらいお魚食べてるでしょうって
おそらく わからないんですけど
でも殺生です で 俗世間の思考を持ってきて
そんなのはもう何て言いますか
世間の節操ではないかと
それが悪いと言ってるんですよ
それが恐ろしいと 世間の節操であることは仏教はわからないと思っているところはちょっとおかしいんですよ
ブッダがそれわからないんですかね
ライオンが鹿を食べなきゃ生きていられないぐらいことのことは
だからそんなところで反論出したっても意味がないんですよ
だって人間が魚食べてるんではないんですか
ですから 漁師さんたちがもう別に罪いたってもしょうがないんではないかとかね
そんなことはブッダがわからないと思っているんですかね
お釈迦様の時代でも漁師もいましたし
動物を殺して肉にして売っている人々ももうすごいたくさんいましたし
その人に他の仕事をできないことを知っているし
まあ面白いことは このサーヴァッティーの祇園精舎でジェータワナ・アナータピンディカ僧伽が
孤児が作ったお寺の隣にいた人が豚を買って豚を殺して生活していたというんですよ
ずっと 他の仕事はない
もう豚をもう買って もう育て育てて
大きくなるなる豚を殺してさばいて店で売る
だから豚肉食べたい人々は
その人のところからまあまあ買うんですね
豚屋さんです で それは知ってますよ
お釈迦様も で だからその人は一つもお寺に足を
お釈迦様ももう長いもういつ
ほとんどそちらに年取ってくると
大体そのお寺で生活していた方長いんだからね
ずっといたわけじゃないんですけど
行ったり来たり行ったり来たりでしたけど
やっぱりすべて設備ができて
お釈迦様にも部屋があって
住むところがあって もう便所やら全部できてあって
もうだから楽でしたし
もう体もね すごく弱くなっていましたし
それでアナータピンディカさんとヴィーサーカ夫人がいつでも面倒見てくれる
必要なものは食べ物やら
それから抜群の一流の医者もいましたし
その医者もブッダの弟子で
もう何かあったらすぐもう治療してくれたりもするし
ですから まあそういうことだから
結構住んでましたけど
隣にいるあの人はもう足一本を入れたことないんですよ
お寺に そこである日 ものすごい豚の鳴き声が聞こえる
朝も聞こえる 昼も聞こえる
夜も聞こえる 次の日も聞こえる
次の日も聞こえる 言ったらアーナンダ尊者がね
あまりもうるさいんですね
うるさいだけじゃなく
すごい気持ち悪いでしょ
生命はすごく大事に思う人にとっては
この殺されるっていうことっていうのは
見るとすっごいこの痛いんですよ
気持ち悪いんではなくて
自分の痛みのように感じちゃうんですよ
すべての生命に対してすごい慈しみを育てちゃうと
もう動物の痛みでも なんとなく自分の痛みのように感じちゃうんですよ
だからアーナンダ尊者にもすごくこれはもう痛くて悲しくてたまらなかったんです
しかし しょうがないんですよ
言ってなんとか言うこともできません
その人のそれしか仕事もないんだから
アーナンダ尊者がお釈迦様にこう言うんですよ
あの隣の人はずっと豚の鳴き声を聞いているんだから
もう朝晩豚殺してるみたいですよと
なんか考えられないんですけど
何かあるでしょうと もしかすると王様やらみんな呼んですっごい盛大に結婚式とか何とか祭りとかやる予定でもあるんでしょうかと
そこまで豚はたくさん殺してるんだからっていうことなんです
そしたらお釈迦様は違いますよと
大きな結婚式やるわけでも
王様は呼ばれて 誰かが大変な晩餐会やる予定があるわけでもないんだよと
あの人が頭狂ってるんだよと
頭狂ってこの豚の鳴き声
叫ぶ声でね 殺す時のね
今泣いてるんだよ それで 1週間もこの頭狂って泣くでしょうと
もう死にますよと これから
死んでも決まってますよ
行くところはもう だって 1週間も頭の中に出てくるあのイメージがね
幻覚が殺されてる豚なんですよ
だから当然いいところに行かないんですよ
だからしょうがないではないかっていうのは
こんな話にならないんです
そういうわけで やっぱりこの重善重悪っていうのは
もうそれは善と悪で もう誰の個人的な好み
社会的な決まりということには関係ないんですよ
例えば人間魚食べるっていうことは
人間が勝手に決めたことであって
それに合わせて宇宙法則変えられますかね
私が足で歩いたりと決めたんだからといって
もうもうすぐ法則変えられますかね
法則は足で歩くようにできてあって
間違った手で歩いたいと思ったっても
そんな簡単に法則は変えられませんよ
だから人間魚食ってるんだっていうことは理由にはなりません
クジラの体がでっかいんだから
たくさん食べなくちゃいけないと思って
これしょうがないんだよ
しょうがないのはわかりますけど
お前が悪いんだと なんでクジラになったんですかと
同族 話なんですよ ではクジラやめてライオンになるぞと
そうすると 1週間  1匹の鹿取っちゃえばいいやということになったら
それでも 1週間一回でもやってますからね
ダメだよと だったらライオンもやめて
何とかにならなくちゃいけないし
でもどちらになったっても
生きることでというのはもう残酷でもう納得いかないもんなんですよ
だから解脱ということを目指しますよと
矛盾が嫌だったらもう悟ることしかないんですね
仏教に矛盾があるわけじゃないんです
殺生するなかれって矛盾だよとかね
今はどんな男もどんな女も自由に遊んでいるんだから
そんなよくしむなく そんなのは時代遅れだと言っても
それは仏教に矛盾があるわけじゃないんです
人間がいろんなことをくだらんことを決めるんだからといってね
よくしもない行為をする人は
明らかに人をバカにしているんです
自分のために人の命を道具にしているんです
自分の家族に対してはものすごい
なんて言いますか 不親切というか
でも 仏教の時代でも一人の男を奥さんは 4人もらったり
10人もらったりはしましたよ
それはよくしない行為じゃないんです
奥さん 10人もらったっていうことは
自分の奥さんたちだから
バカにしてるわけじゃないんですよ
責任持つんですよ ご飯食べさせなくちゃいけないんですよ
子供が生まれたら 自分の子供たちだから面倒見なくちゃいけないんですよ
それで法律的にちゃんと責任持ってもらったら
仏教は全然よくしない行為と言わない
法律を犯して遊ぶことが
これはもう人の権利を奪うことであって悪いとというふうに
だから仏教では別に私は矛盾があるとは思いません
俗世間には矛盾がいっぱいあるんではないかなと思います
そこら辺は考えた方がいいんじゃないかなと
そういうことで この世の中では
やっぱり世の中の思考から見ればね
まあしょうがない しょうがないということは
これは人間が作る決まりで
それと仏教の話は関係ない
仏教の話は全部あくまでもこの地球が丸いと私は言っているような
その基準で言ってるんですよ
地球が丸い このミミズが知らないんだからといって
これはもうどうにもならんですよ
ミミズも丸い地球にいるんです
ミミズが私が知らんだから違いますよと言ったっても
これが話になりません
ですから 私が知らないんだから
世間の決まりだからといって話になりません
これはミミズが自分が反対だと
地球が丸いということに反対だと
ミミズが考えているのは
自分が乗ってこれぐらいの丸さでしょうね
小さな丸い土の粒があったら
ミミズだったらこれだったら丸いんだけど
これが丸いって何で言うんでしょうかとというレベルでしょうね
だから世間の設立とかなんとかっていうことは話になりません
そこは強調するために
お釈迦様は最後に過去の人であろうとも
今の人であろうとも これからの人であろうとも
道徳はこういう風にやるべきですよと言って
この道徳さえも同じ真理ということで語っています
誰がどう踏ん張っても違う解釈はできませんと
だからできるならやってみるというチャレンジはいつでもあるんです
チャレンジするんだったら
かえってこちらもチャレンジするんだよと覚悟して
それ覚悟してないんですね
ただ殴って逃げれると思ってるんですね
それ自体屁理屈でしょうに
まあいくらか私は日本のね
まあ決まりやら社会の習慣にまあ配慮して
手をすごく柔らかくしているだけのことなんですよ
でないと反論はする自由を与える
反論したら その反論の態度によって説明してあげるか
ちょっと解釈してあげるか
壊すか潰すかという それはもう反論の態度なんですよ
だから その場合でも反論する仕方を教えしてるんですよ
誰かが悪い 誰かが正しいという正当するためではなくて
真理を知りたいと 真理を探求しなさいと
[背景音楽]そのことでの反論は正しい反論
その場合は侮辱されません
どんなくだらんことを言ったっても
本人がもう本当のこと知りたくてわざと言ってるんだって
もうこんなこと言ってるんだってすぐ分かりますからね
そういうことで話を終了します
一応結論としては 仏教の道徳も一時的なものではございません
これも普遍的な真理でありますということ
それから もしこの経典は何回何回も自分でも勉強して
内容はすごい単純です
単純のようになってます
これは子供に言ったことなんです
しかし 意味がものすごい深いんですが
で 覚えておけば 我々にも正しく自分の生き方をね
清らかにすること 罪悪のない生き方をする方法っていうのはできると思います
何の疑問もないし 何の矛盾もない
何の疑いもない しっかりした
判断して正しい生き方をするということはできると思います
はい 以上です どうもありがとうございました